redoute une saturation des hôpitaux
[Musique]
c'est chose faite les 27 se sont mis
d'accord pour débloquer le plan de
relance parce qu vide les chefs d'état
européens qui ont entamé ce matin deux
jours de discussions à bruxelles avec au
menu d'éventuelles sanctions contre
ankara mais également le break site
aucune décision ne sera prise avant on
dimanche mais boris johnson lui prévient
il ya une forte possibilité qu'il n'y
ait pas d'accord avec l'union européenne
[Musique]
jean castex a donc tenu une conférence
de presse tout à l'heure il a précisé la
phase suivante prévue pour le 15
décembre pour plus de précisions nous
retrouvons tout de suite on dirait que
notre reporter nadège abderrazak avenue
de ségur boussouar nadège que peut-on
retenir de cette prise de parole très
attendu de premier ministre ce soir
alors comme prévu le déconfinement aura
bel et bien lieu le 15 décembre mais
avec le maintien des restrictions
sanitaires le déconfinement va donc
laisser place un couvre feu nocturne de
20 heures à 6 heures du matin un
couvre-feu qui sera strictement contrôlé
à en croire jean castex le ministre de
l'intérieur elle gérald darmanin qui a
accompagné le premier ministre
aujourd'hui lors de ce point presse et
bien a prévenu que le non respect de ce
un couvre feu sera puni d'une amende de
135 euros s'en sera fini également de
l'attestation en journée puisque lé
déplacement seront autorisées partout en
france a noté également la fermeture
pour au moins trois semaines
supplémentaires des lieux de
rassemblement cinéma théâtre ou encore
salle de spectacle on écoute justement
jean castex à ce sujet mais les règles
seront plus stricts que ceux que nous
avions initialement envisagé première
décision
les établissements recevant du public
dont nous avions prévu la réouverture au
15 décembre resteront fermées trois
semaines de plus les conditions posées
pour leur réouverture ne sont hélas pas
réunies il s'agit principalement des
cinémas des théâtres les salles de
spectacles des musées mais aussi de
l'accueil du public dans l'es17 sportive
dans les cirques les parcs zoologiques
ou encore les salles de jeux et des
casinos
cela signifie également que les règles
posées récemment pour les lieux de culte
ne seront pas revus à la rose qu'en est
il des fêtes de fin d'année pourra-t-on
les célébrer en famille ça sera oui pour
noël non pour le réveillon du jour de
l'an est le couvre feu sera donc
maintenus pour la soirée de la saint
sylvestre avec cette recommandation pas
plus de six personnes à table
en revanche on aurait pu penser que
cette mesure soit aussi appliqué pour
noël jean castex dit non pourquoi et
bien parce que noël tient une place
importante dit-il dans nos vies dans nos
traditions alors le couvre-feu sera donc
levé pour le 24 décembre pas besoin
d'attestation pour se déplacer à des
mesures qui peuvent paraître difficiles
voire incompréhensible mais justifié un
qualifié de nécessaire par le premier
ministre pour justement éviter une
éventuelle troisième vague de l'épidémie
t nous savons que les fêtes de fin
d'année à noël ou pour le nouvel an
constituent des moments particulièrement
à risque
le retour d'expérience de ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis ou au canada pour
les fêtes de thanksgiving le démontre
amplement puisque chaque fois c'est fait
ont entraîné une accélération de
l'épidémie
pour toutes ces raisons nous ne pouvons
pas baisser la garde
nous devons rester cohérent et négocier
les prochaines semaines avec beaucoup de
vigilance
nous devons adapter nos mesures autour
d'un objectif permettre à chacune et
chacun de profiter des vacances et des
fêtes de fin d'année mais sans nous
exposer à un risque de rebond de
l'épidémie ni maintenant ni dans les
premières semaines de janvier car je
pense que nous serons tous d'accord sur
ce point
faisons tout ce que nous pouvons pour
réduire le risque de devoir vivre un
troisième confinement dans les prochains
mois c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
sous l'autorité du président de la
république d'adapter la stratégie de
déconfinement en pleine cohérence avec
ceux qui vous avait été présentée le 24
novembre dernier déconfinement 15
décembre et l'instauration d'un
couvre-feu nocturne voilà ce que l'on
pouvait retenir ce soir de ce point
presse de jean castex le premier
ministre qui était donc accompagné à
l'occasion de son ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand et de gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur merci nadège
abderrazak en direct de l'avenue de
ségur et pour revenir sur cette
situation sanitaire et les nouvelles
annonces du premier ministre place à
notre décryptage avec nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric jeanjean restaurateurs patron
de la brasserie des templiers à
marseille secrétaire général l'umih 13
bonsoir frédéric jeanjean merci d'être
avec nous jean jacques 15 ans brosse qui
médecin hospitalier l'hôpital bichat
économiste de la santé à l'université
paris descartes bonsoir à vous aussi et
enfin alain houpert sénateur les
républicains de la côte-d'or bonsoir à
vous aussi
là on perd merci d'être là je vais
commencer par la réaction du politique
que vous êtes jean castex voilà qui
appelle à la responsabilité restrictions
renforcées notamment dans le couvre-feu
un couvre-feu les cinémas et la culture
attendront mais dans le même temps on
allège avec un déconfinement le 15
décembre vous l'avez trouvé comment jean
castex
j'ai trouvé comme à son habitude mais il
ya eu deux temps forts aujourd'hui il ya
eu l'expression du premier ministre du
ministre de la santé il ya eu aussi au
sénat la chambre haute
la sortie du rapport sur la gestion de
la crise fait sanitaires
un rapport de 4 152 pages que j'ai
essayer d'avaler cet après midi une
commission qui a écouté 133 personnes
qui est ce rapport pointe une politique
de santé
guidés par la doctrine technocratique et
la logique budgétaire au détriment des
patients qui devrait en être le centre
donc est ce rapport pointe l'absence
d'anticipation de l'état qui repose sur
de mauvaises décisions
un vrai faux rapports une réécriture de
l'histoire et cela fait beaucoup pour un
gouvernement qui réclame la confiance
des français pour une stratégie
sanitaire
c'est à dire on va y revenir parce que
vous faites allusion effectivement
jérôme salomon notamment qui est le
directeur
de l' agence régionale de 200 de la
haute autorité de santé qui est visé par
ce rapport on va y revenir aux sénateurs
si vous le voulez bien dans quelques
instants mais j'aimerais tout d'abord
effectivement et ce à un lien vous avez
raison débriefer ce point presse de jean
castex
ça veut dire frédéric jeanjean que c'est
dans cette lignée de la mauvaise gestion
de la crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement ou le gouvernement prend
quand même les bonnes décisions selon
vous comment vous l'avez vous les avez
accueilli ces annonces ce soir
j'écoutais jusqu'à maintenant ils se
sont trompés leurs prévisions ils se
sont encore retrouvés comme jeudi avec
le nombre de fois où il pleut ou il se
plante et oui nous plante je crois qu'au
printemps avoir des récoltes fantastique
parce que ça devient dramatique ça
devient dramatique parce que rappelez
vous la première phase de confinement
mais les masques on met pas les masques
la maintenance et on va ouvrir
finalement n'ouvre plus vous savez nous
qu'est ce qu'on a entendu ce soir qu'on
repoussée de trois semaines pour les
salles de spectacle mais on sait très
bien que nous derrière on a le risque de
d'avoir encore trois semaines de plus
et puis vous savez ils disent qu'ils
accompagnent au maximum moi je cet après
midi je sais pas si vous pouvez passer
les images nous en sommes réduits nous
puisque nous en sommes troisièmes
confinement à faire une banque
alimentaire avec nos fournisseurs pour
pouvoir aider les chefs d'entreprises
qui n'ont plus les moyens de subvenir au
quotidien je distribue des pâtes de la
farine de l'huile des oeufs
on en est à ça mais je vais vous
annoncer encore quelque chose
des gens qui sont complètement de passer
sous les radars c'est le portage
salarial
parce qu'ils n'ont pas droit au chômage
partiel et ils n'ont pas droit aux aides
en tant que chef d'entreprise et ils
n'ont rien et beaucoup se trouvent dans
une difficulté une détresse qui sont
absolument indescriptible
donc en termes de gestion excusez moi
mais c'est un zéro pointé aux chefs
d'entreprise
j'essaye d'anticiper j'essaye de prévoir
et là on nous apprend que
encore une fois les prévisions tout ce
qu'ils ont pu essayer d'envisager
d'entrevoir ils se sont plantés
écoutez je crois que c'est dans tous les
mauvais écouter jean castex sur ce thème
puisque vous faisiez allusion à ces
aides
le premier ministre qui défend lui
plutôt son bilan le bilan du
gouvernement sur ce plan écouter pour
les commerces qui ont dû fermer en
novembre le formulaire d'accès aux aides
a été mis en ligne le 4 décembre et 372
1000 entreprises ont déjà touché les
versements pour un montant total de près
de 2 milliards d'euros
en ce moment ce sont encore 1 million
600 mille salariés qui bénéficient de
l'activité partielle notamment dans
l'hôtellerie la restauration ou encore
l'événementiel nous continuons à
améliorer et à compléter nos dispositifs
pour que personne ne soit laissé de côté
le fonds de solidarité pourra désormais
bénéficier aussi aux prestataires
exploitants agricoles travaillant avec
le secteur de l'hôtellerie et de la
restauration ou aux sous traitants du
monde de l'événementiel notamment
sportifs et culturels
on va faire réagir dans quelques
instants évidemment le docteur en gros
ce qui est aussi sur la partie médicale
mais mais tout de même puisque vous avez
lancé le sujet en frédéric jeanjean sur
ces entreprises le premier ministre
défend son bilan c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
un chômage partiel important en france
il n'empêche qu'il ya beaucoup d'auto
entrepreneur de petits commerçants qui
risque tout simplement leur peau qui
rompt déjà d'ailleurs mis pour beaucoup
la clé sous la porte allain ou père
votre réaction sur ce point le bilan le
gouvernement même un bon bilan
maternaide par rapport peut-être à
d'autres pays j'entends
l'autosatisfaction du gouvernement par
la parole du premier ministre mais
j'entends aussi la souffrance des petits
commerçants et en particulier des
restaurateurs ou parler de chômage
partiel mais sur l'as partiel il est
partial et concerne les salariés pas les
entrepreneurs et puis on a complètement
oublié le problème des congés payés
parce que quand vous êtes au chômage
partiel l'employeur doit payer des
congés payés
ça va peser lourd dans la balance et les
aides ne sont pas significatives ne sont
pas assez importantes
les entrepreneurs dans la restauration
ce sont souvent des jeunes des jeunes
qui ont acheté le droit au bail et qui
payent des loyers souvent dans les
grandes villes pharaonique et on a un
monsieur jeanjean de marseille et
marseille n'échappe pas à la règle de
toutes les métropoles
ces gens là avec les aides n'arrivent
même pas à payer leur loyer dont ils
font obligés de négocier avec leur
bailleur
c'est un drame c'est un drame important
on va voir bientôt dans les tribunaux de
commerce
ddd que mais dès que deux pour de
pauvres des redressements judiciaires et
des faillites
et ça c'est grave parce que le plus gros
employeur en france c'est l'artisanat
n'oublions pas que le repas français a
été classé à l'unesco comme patrimoine
immatériel et le tourisme c'est quand
même la première industrie française qui
est sacrifié sur l'autel de la pandémie
a doctor ambrose qui quand vous écoutez
là frédéric jeanjean et le sénateur ou
père il ya toujours ces deux fronts qui
semble inexorablement s'affronter entre
la santé d'un côté et l'économie de
l'autre qui commence vraiment on le voit
faire
voilà des ravages je pense que il faut
pas se tromper
je suis professeur de politique et
d'économie de la santé je sais que le
sénateur ou père est également médecin
il faut pas se tromper
malheureusement et c'est dramatique le
monde de la restauration de l'hôtellerie
de la culture paient un tribut terrible
à cette pandémie chez nos voisins ça ne
va guère mieux à part ici ou là telle ou
telle exception comme c'est pas de
bétail ont bien pourquoi les stations de
sports d'hiver où les remontées
mécaniques fonctionnent chez nos voisins
suisses
mais si on regarde par exemple bilan
allemand la mortalité
le nombre de personnes hospitalisées il
est devenu le double de ce qu'il est
chez nous encore une fois il faut pas se
tromper
malheureusement cette pandémie peut-être
n'at-elle pas été bien gérée jeu
l'histoire le dira peut-être n'at-on pas
pris les bonnes mesures peut être
effectivement à te manquer de masques
pour appliquer la politique qui aurait
été nécessaire et on voit que les seuls
pays qui n'ont pas été balayés par cette
pandémie dramatiques sont ceux où la
distanciation social le port du masque
le dépistage etc ont été véritablement
assuré je ne parle pas de la chine et
des pays à un régime plus policiers que
le nôtre où la discipline est assuré
d'une manière que nous ne savons à
l'évidence pas faire chez nous
d'ailleurs que nous ne semble-t-il
supporterions pas mais du point de vue
médical
la pandémie dont on pensait qu'elle
allait régressé que les chiffres
allaient s'améliorer ne s'est pas
améliorée et sans prendre parti ni pour
les uns ni pour les autres et tout en
étant croyez le bien plus que ce leader
du drame que vivent les commerçants les
restaurateurs les hôteliers les gens qui
ont un bar un lieu de culture les
responsables de salles de spectacles que
ce soit à paris à marseille ou dans les
beaucoup plus petites villes
c'est un drame mais malheureusement
l'épidémie est un drame
la pandémie est un drame au début on ne
pensait certains ont dit c'est une
simple cryptée qui fera chaud ça va
passer ça n'est pas passé on a dit c'est
une simple grippe
eh bien non et même si il y à une
mortalité relativement limitée jeudi
relativement et bien il se trouve que
les séquelles neurologiques
cardiologique que la maladie laisse y
compris chez des sujets jeunes de 40 ans
de 50 ans à peine sont absolument
redoutable et qu'on se rend compte que
on ne sait pas encore tout de ce virus
quant à ceux qui se lancent dans un
vaccin hasardeuse qui n'a pas encore
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
eh bien ce sont des aventuriers je prie
pour qu'ils aient eu raison
j'espère qu'ils auront eu raison mais là
peu par les docteurs ignorant qu'il faut
être très humble on va on va en parler
si vous le voulez bien de ce mec ça on
va rester sur ces mesures
vous parlez de voir cette pandémie
malheureusement qui ne s'améliore pas
loin de là trois constats pour lesquels
nous n'avons pas atteint un objectif
selon olivier verront que l'on écoute
plusieurs observations peuvent être
réalisées d'abord nous n'atteindrons pas
les 5000 diagnostic par jour au 15
décembre
deuxième constat les conditions
climatiques vont évidemment durée
puisque l'hiver va progressivement ça
allez troisième constat les vacances et
les fêtes de fin d'année vont augmenter
de manière importante nos contacts
sociaux
le risque est donc si nous ne changeons
rien que la deuxième vague
repartez dans les prochaines semaines
que les cas graves se remettent à
augmenter nous l'avons déjà connu alors
là on perd c'est fait qu'ils sont en
danger évidemment on l'a vu aux états
unis avec une explosion des cas après
france bing alors on va pouvoir fêter
noël mais mais pas nouvelle en vous êtes
d'accord avec sa préconisation du
gouvernement cette annonce en tout cas
j'ai bien entendu mon confrère le
professeur de médecine de politique de
santé
moi je fais de la politique je suis
médecin et je fais de la politique et je
livre c'est important de pointer ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui on a mis le
doigt où ça faisait mal sur deux
scandales celui de monsieur salomon
jérôme salomon qui a et je tiens à
insister là-dessus outil qui a en
octobre 2018 a choisi de ne pas
reconstituer les stocks de masques sans
en avertir la ministre agnès buzyn les
deuxième scandale entre yb et là entre
guillemets c'est que monsieur vers en
affirmant que l'impréparation du pays
remonte à 2011
et aujourd'hui on a prouvé que
l'impréparation du pays remonte à
octobre 2018
nous avons été obligés le 15 juin 2020
d'acheter 3,9 milliards de masques dont
2,7 milliards en chine soit un coût de
2,8 milliards d'euros qui s'ajoutent aux
2 milliards pour les entreprises
nous sommes face à une catastrophe
sanitaire et josh et et un avenir
difficile et je rejoins le professeur
tout à l'heure sur les sur les vaccins
où il faut pas que les scientifiques se
transforme en apprenti sorcier et sur
une crise économique et sur une crise
sociale profonde
les gens n'en peuvent plus moi je vois
encore des patients je travaille
à temps partiel je vois de jour en jour
se dégrader le moral des français est
moral des français le moral des
personnes âgées qui ne vont pas voir
qu'ils vont pas voir leur leur famille
et je lisais dernièrement le livre de
d'erik orsenna son dernier livre où il
disait que la plus grande ronde de
l'histoire c'est d'interdire aux
personnes âgées qui sont à la fin de
leur vie de voir leur leurs proches pour
dire au revoir
nous sommes dans une crise qui dépasse
qui dépasse l'économie qui dépasse
sanitaire qui atteint le moral des
français est l'offre
le président de la république a parlé de
guerre et en en réduisant les marges de
manoeuvre aux médecins imaginer le
général de gaulle une phase général de
gaulle qui en quarante appels à résister
sans armes
frédéric jeanjean quand vous écoutez
alain houpert vous parler de la détresse
psychologique voilà de nombreux de nos
concitoyens vous vous imaginez vous
constatez au quotidien dans la banque
alimentaire que vous avez créé tout à
fait là compagnon le lycée même d'aller
au delà
on a même mis en place des structures
pour la prévention du suicide parce
qu'on en arrive à ça vous savez tous
alors on disait que le 31 décembre
n'aurait pas lieu
mais où parce que quand on regarde les
locations de matériel de sonorisation
n'y a plus rien de disponible pour le 31
décembre a osé ce qui se passe et on
empêche pas la réelle il les gens de
vivre
donc ils vont arriver avant de partir
ils vont s'installer dans une maison
pendant deux jours ils vont faire le 31
décembre et il ya plus de sono il ya
plus d'éclairage il ya plus de pendant
que dans mes établissements ou des
restaurants par exemple on pourrait
faire un repas avec des gestes mariant
protocole sanitaire dans des
établissements où on fait attention on a
mis en place toutes les procédures et je
comprends bien que ce problème de la
contamination
mais au moins c'était quand même
beaucoup plus contrôlés que ceux qu'on
va avoir
c'est à dire des gens qui vont se
retrouver ils vont partir s'ils peuvent
circuler dans la journée
ils vont arriver à deux heures de
l'après-midi ils vont faire la fête
pendant deux jours et puis ils vont
sortir de là avec l'alcool avec les
stupéfiants qui circulent à tour de bras
en ce moment et ça va être du grand
n'importe quoi voilà alors on rajoute ça
à l'impréparation qu'on a vu au premier
confinement qu'on a vu à l'heure
actuelle vous savez moi je peux vous en
parler
le premier ministre se félicite des
aides qui arrive je dirais enfin on nous
les a annoncé nous nous avons dans une
troisième confinement à marseille on
nous avait annoncé des aides quand on
nous a fermé sun septembre début octobre
qui devait arriver immédiatement les a
touché fin novembre
mais pendant deux mois il a fallu faire
face avec un effondrement de l'activité
parce qu'on avait des couvre-feux parce
qu'on avait tous ces problèmes là il
faut payer des loyers
on nous avait annoncé les banques qui a
cessé ses aides sont arrivés on va on va
donner pardonnez moi parce que vous êtes
3 c'est vrai qu'il faut distribuer la
parole équitablement jean-jacques un
nombre ce qui comme vous écouter
frédéric jeanjean et sa détresse et et
nous parler un petit peu de ces
incohérences est vrai que là le premier
ministre nous annonce que finalement on
va les cinémas les théâtres et les
musées ne rouvrons pas le 15 décembre
ils sont restés ils resteront fermés
encore trois semaines et pourtant il
avait mis en place un protocole
sanitaires très strictes c'est vrai que
c'est un petit peu rageant vous l'avez
dit oui ok c'est un virus ou on est tous
victimes mais il n'y a pas un peu quand
même une incohérence et d'impréparation
ne sait pas où on va vraiment je crois
que malheureusement le problème est très
difficile à régler pourquoi c'est pas le
fait d'être dans un restaurant où les
mesures ont été remarquablement prises
par les professionnels j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler avec plusieurs
organisations professionnelles autour de
lui et me h dont monsieur jeanjean et le
responsable à marseille avec différents
propriétaires de l'établissement à paris
qui appartenait à 7 cette union des
métiers et industries de l'hôtellerie et
de la restauration ce sont des grands
professionnels ils ont mis des gestes
barrières en place le problème qu'on
craint et que les autorités sanitaires
redoutent sait pas ce qui peut passer
dans un restaurant où les gestes
barrière existe ou la distanciation
existe ou où tout est tout est organisé
c'est le fait de se concentrer de
circuler dans la rue et alors
effectivement l'autre incohérences
il y en a à l'évidence à sont par
exemple les transports en commun qui à
paris comme à marseille sont
certainement bon départ ce que les
organisations de transport en commun ou
diviser par deux leurs offres mais que
les nombres de gens qui circulent parce
qu'on les encourage à aller travailler
et que tout le monde ne télétravail pas
et bien s'entassent dans le métro
parisien
comme dans les bus comme j'imagine à
marseille là aussi dans les bus et les
tramways donc il ya effectivement des
incohérences et je pense que à un moment
donné les responsabilités seront établis
ce sera le rôle des politiques des
commissions d'enquêté des uns des autres
mais pour l'instant on a à faire face à
une urgence de santé non seulement on ne
peut pas faire face exagérément à un
trop plein de patients dans le système
hospitalier
ça c'est vrai encore que j'entendais ce
matin un collègue dans mon propre
établissement hospitalier car il pas
médecin qui a perdu la main et le
contact avec le malade tant s'en faut
moi non plus mais qui disait s'il le
fallait on pourrait ouvrir 150 lits
dédiés aux qu'ovide quitte à dédier les
a envoyé les malades des autres
pathologies dans d'autres établissements
qui eux seraient covit free c'est à dire
exemple que vides sans risque de
contamination à paris comme à marseille
comme à lyon comme dans les grandes
villes il ya plusieurs établissements
pourraient les répartir mieux que tout
ça soit des fautes de gestion des
différentes institutions
il sera temps de l'établir et encore une
fois je ne suis pas le responsable
politique c'est le sénateur
justement on va terminer attendant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
on verra face à la maladie et aux formes
qui nécessite pas d'hospitalisation mais
qui laisse des dizaines de patients des
milliers de patients dans la détresse et
qui ont des séquelles graves
c'est ça le problème et on se payer le
luxe d'une troisième crise médicale
économique sociale sociétale et
politique en plus ne nous arrangerait
vraiment pas y'a qu'à voir ce qui se
passe chez nos voisins italiens ou
allemands aujourd'hui pourra parler vrai
des britanniques qu'ils vaccinent sur un
vaccin non autorisée justement jouer
vous êtes à transition le mot de la fin
pour alain houpert vous a entendu parler
de ce rapport et on va d'ailleurs y
revenir longuement 21h sur cette mise en
cause de
jérôme salomon mais sur le vaccin là on
perd vous espérer une meilleure gestion
vous êtes optimiste sur le choix qu'a
fait la france avec l'europe d'être
peut-être plus prudent contrairement au
royaume uni et même pas passé en
procédure d'urgence et d'attendre
peut-être l'année prochaine pour la
vaccination ça sera le mot de la fin
rapidement ce nom complet je suis
inquiet parce que c'est l'europe qui
gère ça et quand on a vu la gestion par
le ram des civils le 8 le 8 octobre
dernier on achète pour 2 milliards
d'euros
deux doses et puis trois jours après l
oms se dit que c'est pas raisonnable
parce que c'était ce produit est
dangereux
donc si l'europe nous met dans la même
dans la même position ça va être
difficile à gérer mais je voudrais
revenir sur le restaurateur faut pas
oublier que les restaurateurs ont fait
des dépenses extraordinaires des
fortunes pour mettre en place les gestes
barrières et que ceux des dépenses les
ont encore fragilisé et pour les vaccins
on va utiliser un vaccin arn messager je
ne suis pas grandes épidémies logistique
quoi que ce soit mais j'ai quand même
fait quelques études de médecine et
c'est un peu une thérapie génique qu'on
n'a pas encore utilisé sur le mode
vaccinale et je pense qu'on invoque sein
jusqu'à présent avec ça on mettait même
un médicament dix années de recul
1 et là on a fait confiance au
communiqué de presse de laboratoire on
n'a aucune donnée données soupçon n'a
aucune aucune donnée donc et je pense
que le sait le deus makina des
gouvernements il n'y a pas que le nôtre
pour rassurer la population mais la
population qu'elles seront elles un elle
est éclairée
ouais merci beaucoup en tout cas alain
houpert jean-jacques en brosse qui est
frédéric jeanjean d'avoir été avec nous
après donc ce point presse de jean
castex persie à tous les trois restez
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons de l'europe a également foyer
de l'épidémie confrontés
elle aussi une deuxième vague de corona
virus un virus qui contraint les
gouvernements réticents à revenir au
confinement ou aux restrictions et puis
direction bruxelles où les dirigeants de
l'union européenne ont entamé
aujourd'hui un sommet de deux jours
un compromis a été trouvé sur le plan de
relance parce qu'au pic
[Musique]
et
détails sony qui a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et smith est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelque part
dans notre politique internationale vis
bien évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de jihad
et de cet appel d'air justement ou aux
crues du mans l'a malheureusement fait
en syrie en irak
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond appartement on est énervé dans le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je vois des macros il passe un tour
de tracts avec une grande campagne il
faut savoir c'est qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait aider un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez le vieux
continent à la peine face sadate
deuxième vague de virus le nombre de
nouveaux cas ne cesse d'augmenter et les
pays qui avaient pourtant réussi
jusqu'ici à contrôler la pandémie comme
l'allemagne le danemark ou la suède sont
de plus en plus inquiet on fait le point
avec amaya son blé
ce sont des pays qui servait d'exemple
en matière de gestion du coc vide qui se
retrouvent désormais dans la tourmente
l'allemagne le danemark et la suède se
voit prendre de nouvelles décisions pour
gérer cette pandémie mondiale
angéla merkel appelle à plus de
restrictions et avec plus de 20000 cas
recensés en 24 heures ce jeudi les
mesures actuellement en vigueur sont
insuffisantes
la chancelière a appelé à réduire les
contacts alors que les services de
réanimation arrive pour certains déjà à
saturation et bien la fin et lorsque
nous manquons de personnel et que nous
devons passer à un autre mode de soins à
une sorte de médecine de catastrophe
dans laquelle les infirmières et les
médecins doivent s'occuper de beaucoup
plus de patients qu'ils n'en n'ont
l'habitude les capacités théoriques des
lits de soins intensifs où d'autres
lycées muller qui dispose au moins deux
moniteurs et de ventilateurs que nous
avons créés au cours des dernières
semaines et des derniers mois mais c'est
le personnel infirmier
le personnel médical qui n'est tout
simplement pas l'arrêt qui nous inquiète
beaucoup
et du côté du danemark les semis mesures
prises ces derniers mois vont être
étendus à 38 communes dont les trois
principales villes du pays un nombre
record de 3130 de cas ayant été recensés
en 24 heures le pays a désormais passé
la barre des 100000 qu'à la première
ministre appelle la population à rester
chez elle et à ne pas se rassembler
du côté des danois l'inquiétude se fait
de plus en plus ressentir comprend
pourquoi il faut faire quelque chose
le nombre de cas augmente augmente
augmente il ne s'améliore pas mais en
même temps j'ai l'impression que les
gens pourraient se rencontrer chez eux
maintenant quand ils ne peuvent pas
sortir dans un environnement contrôlé
ils vont aller dans un environnement non
contrôlé à la main
son dernier pas des moindres la suède le
bon élève européen qui a longtemps évité
le confinement s'est vu obligé de
changer de cap à la proche d'une
deuxième vague
les lycées sont à nouveau fermés depuis
ce lundi et ce jusqu'au 6 janvier
mesures qui s'ajoutent à l'interdiction
de la vente d'alcool après 22h et une
jauge fixé à 8 personnes pour les
événements publics
le chef du service de santé lance un
appel à l'aide les lits de réanimation
sont désormais occupés à 99% à stockholm
une deuxième vague qui semble donc hors
de contrôle pour nos voisins européens
même pour ces pays qui semblait il y a
encore quelques semaines plus épargné
que le nôtre et pour parler de la
situation en suède
nous sommes en direct depuis elles sont
borg avec un niels feinstein externes
non médecin à l'hôpital de l'undp c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir nils fast remercie à d'autres
avec nous en direct sur rt france est
vrai que la suède on en a beaucoup parlé
lors de la première vague il faisait
plutôt office d'exemple on voit que la
situation se dégrade
comment on se l'expliquent sur place
alors oui il est vrai que le nom de le
nombre de cas depuis la mi-octobre
augmentent de manière exponentielle
ce qui est très triste je suis pas un
expert en virologie je pense que c'est
très difficile à dire je pense que deux
hypothèses sont plausibles
d'abord c'est un virus qui est très
certainement saisonniers comme une
grippe donc les restrictions sont restés
les mêmes jusqu'à récemment
depuis mars mais malheureusement une
nouvelle vague est apparue en octobre
donc c'est un virus qui probablement
très probalement saisonniers et de plus
si le virus a probablement muter ce qui
ce qui fait que dès réinfection son
possible aussi de nombreuses études qui
ont été publiés qui monte des cas de
réinfection sur sur les mêmes patients
donc je pense que ce virus probablement
reviendra à chaque hiver jusqu'à ce
qu'on trouve une situation durable les
propos potentiellement un vaccin ou
autres mesures
vous vous êtes médecin effectivement on
nous parlait dans ce reportage de la
situation dans les hôpitaux à stockholm
99% des nids de réanimation sont occupés
c'est bien ça ça présage de ce qui peut
se passer sur le reste du territoire
alors c'est une division c'est une
situation qui est très difficile à
stockholm et effectivement c'est
stockhom c'est la capitale où la plus
grande concentration de personnes et les
services de réanimation sont surmenés
après si on regarde au niveau national
on a hier on avait deux cent cinquante
neuf personnes qui étaient en
réanimation simultanément alors qu'en
avril le pic était à 522 donc plus du
double de cas en réanimation
simultanément donc les capacités
nationales ne sont ne sont absolument
pas compte encore
mais la situation est très sérieuse il
ya un nombre de cas qui est beaucoup
plus élevé par jour toutefois c'est
parce qu'aussi pas ce conte est beaucoup
plus mais il ya quand même un gros taux
d'infection mais il ya moins de cas
hospitalisés et d'aucuns en réanimation
que pendant la première vague alors là
le gouvernant a pris des mesures on a
entendu la fermeture des lycées est ce
qu'on vous en tant que médecin s'avoue
satisfait les mesures du gouvernement
sont plutôt bien accueillies en suède
juste une petite précision je suis
externe pas pas encore aux médecins mais
écoutez je trouve que les mesures sont
bien elles et des gens les gens les
prennent très au sérieux c'est à dire
qu'il n'y a pas de de loi on va dire
comme en france on laisse de se prendre
des amendes etc
c'est plus des recommandations et les
gens les suivent à la lettre mois pour
être dans le milieu encore étudiant ce
pouvoir que que même les étudiants qui
pourrait être la catégorie sociale qui
serait amené à la respecter l'eau - les
restrictions le font vraiment à fond
donc c'est de n'être en contact avec les
personnes avec lesquelles on vit et si
l'on vit seul choisir une ou deux
personnes avec qui on peut passer du
temps mais pas plus il fermait également
les restaurants n'a plus droit de servir
de l'alcool après 22h 30 fermeture de
salles de gym 200 commerces etc
donc il y à des mesures de la suite
prend apprend c'est le deuxième vague
très au sérieux alors c'est étonnant
parce qu'il ya eu un gros débat vous
étiez un petit peu l'exemple ou le
contre exemple un c'est selon où il n'y
avait pas finalement de grandes
restrictions lors de la première vague
le gouvernement avait choisi justement
d'être plutôt le libéral de l'essai
voilà les personnes à leur
responsabilité de ne pas trop imposer
des restrictions
aujourd'hui ces volte face on pourrait
dire ça je pense que la stratégie de la
suède dans cette première partie de 2020
était de tout d'abord de limiter la
propagation du virus pour ne pas
surcharger les ne pas surcharger les
services de réanimation et je pense que
ça on a réussi à le faire mais comme
j'ai dit précédemment ce virus et les
problèmes en saisonnier il mute
je pense qu'on ne pourra pas empêcher la
propagation du virus
complètement
donc si on dresse un bilan de la suède
par rapport aux autres pays d'europe je
pense pas qu'on a un bilan qui est moins
bon que les pays qui ont confiné et le
confinement finalement qu'est ce que ça
fait c'est ça permet de limiter les
dégâts momentanément mais ça ne fera pas
disparaître le virus donc il faudra
espérer un vaccin ou d'autres solutions
alors justement le vaccin on y vient
puisque l'europe a fait une commande
groupée donc tous les pays européens en
théorie seront à peu près traités de la
même manière vaccination en début
d'année prochaine commence à se profile
justement chez vous en suède
quelle est la stratégie de votre
gouvernement alors la stratégie la
famille elle est simple c'est de ces
deux d'abord dans un premier temps
vacciner les personnels hospitaliers et
les groupes à risque et donc tous ceux
qui sont au dessus de 65 ans ou qui ont
des d'éco mobilité des facteurs de
comorbidité qui sont qui son potentiel
et dans un deuxième temps commencer à
vacciner la population plus généralement
mais ça on en parle on ne parle pas de
date fixe probablement me printemps
alors sauf que incarnant des suédois n'a
pas confiance on avec sein développée en
urgence à cause notamment de la vaste
campagne au contrô le h100 achats et non
c'était en 2009
alors oui mais c c c est difficile de
faire confiance de faire confiance en
entreprise qui a développé un vaccin si
rapidement je pense que énormément
d'argent a été débloquée pour pour faire
de la recherche là dessus moi même je ne
serai pas dire si je veux me faire
vacciner directement et et j'attends de
voir quelques quelques études en plus
pour vérifier si le bac 5 d'un efficace
merci à nils faire strom externe en
médecine à l'hôpital de lund en suède
merci à vous bonne nouvelle pour l'union
européenne les 27 membres viennent de
débloquer et le plan de relance posco
vie d'agent va charger en cette fin de
semaine plusieurs dossiers à traiter la
pandémie de coronavirus un budget
européen crucial pour ces prochaines
années ou encore le comportement de la
turquie en mer méditerranée
état des lieux avec walid
annie les visages fermés et pas décidé
les plus grands dirigeants européens
réunis à bruxelles l'union européenne
à la croisée des chemins celui du
compromis ou celui d'une crise majeure
vous savez il ya eu un blocage très
important sur l'état de droit et un
compromis est en train d'être trouvées
je souhaite que nous puissions finaliser
ce compromis dans les heures qui
viennent et permettre et bien à la fois
au budget des prochaines années comme au
plan de relance européen que nous avons
tous ensemble acté en juillet dernier
vient d'être finalisé et de voir ses
premiers paiements vraiment à devenir
dans les prochaines semaines démocratie
et unités en ces temps compliqués en
pleine pandémie objectif premier
survivre et dirigeants européens n'ont
pas tardé à débloquer ce jeudi le plan
de relance posco vide estimé à 750
milliards d'euros votée l'été dernier
une année 2000 vendre à oublier mais des
perspectives à construire pour l'avenir
mais contours du budget de l'union
européenne pour les sept prochaines
années
finalement dessiner la hongrie et la
pologne réticents souhaitait éviter
toute condition arbitraire pour un
versement des fonds une enveloppe de
plus de 1000 milliards d'euros désormais
disponibles tous dérivés alfort est une
faute de youn était à voir aujourd'hui
nous nous battons pour l'unité de notre
continent commun à nous devons nous
comporter de manière raisonnable et
trouver un moyen d'adopter des approches
fiable et de faire triompher le bon sens
pour fournir des services de santé en
cas de pandémie aux personnes qui en ont
besoin et pour apporter une aide
financière aux pays qui sont réellement
dans le besoin pour aider leur
population sur fond de craintes ce soir
il une étourderie fausse l'environnement
au coeur des négociations
l'allemagne insiste notamment pour
réduire les émissions de co2 d'au moins
25% d'ici 2030 et atteindre la
neutralité climatique d'ici 2050 un
objectif collectif est à l'étude
autre dossier brûlant celui de la
turquie ces opérations dans les eaux
territoriales de chypre en ligne de mire
nous devons défendre la souveraineté des
états de l'union européenne et la
stabilité en particulier en méditerranée
orientale elle la turquie membre
important de l'otan
les vingt-sept souhaitent désormais
associer les états unis dans de
prochaines décisions concernant le pays
du président r doan et pour en parler
nous sommes avec un thierry mariani
député européen du rassemblement
national
bonsoir thierry
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors on commence avec cette
nouvelle de la soirée un accord donc
validée sur le plan de relance c'est une
nouvelle dont vous réjouissez écoutez
c'est conforme à la tradition européenne
où après des réunions marathon la salle
a pas été tellement marathon il ya
finalement un accord qui est trouvé
c'est un peu tôt pour se dire si les
informations qu'on a parce qu'on n'a pas
encore toutes les informations cet
accord vient juste d'être annoncé 6 qui
est le gagnant qui est le perdant mais
l'essentiel j'ai envie de dire c'est que
d'abord la hongrie et la pologne ont
marqué qu'on pouvait résister et
finalement je pense en or une sorte de
victoire tactique puisque les éléments
d'information dont on dispose
aujourd'hui c'est quoi asteur si on nous
dit en réalité la pologne et la hongrie
on va accepter la question de l'état de
droit
mais en cas de litige cet état de droit
sera soumis à la cour européenne de
justice ce qui veut dire quoi ce qui
veut dire en clair que il y aurait une
victoire j'ai presque envie de dire
tactique de monsieur urban et de la
pologne pourquoi parce que quand on
connaît les mécanismes d'application des
décisions de la cour européenne de
justice en réalité c'est extrêmement
compliqué et il ya peu de chance qu'un
jour cela arrive je vais dire à être
efficace et mai et une victoire de
monsieur sorbonne parce que finalement
avec la pologne ils toucheront les aides
que l'union européenne avait touché par
quoi que j'ai envie de dire c'est si
c'est une victoire quand puisqu'ils
auront ces fonds c'est aussi un
peut-être un peu une défaite je trouve
paradoxal que sur les principes
finalement il décide de se soumettre à
la justice européenne une fois de plus
les mariannes et justement justement
avant même d'attendre l'issue de ce
sommet le ministre hongrois des affaires
étrangères s'était félicité à l'issue du
bras de fer parlant d'une victoire
on nous a informés que l'excès de la
hongrie au fonds européen ne serait pas
liée à des conditions politiques ou
idéologiques
une réaction justement cette déclaration
oui là c'est clairement une victoire là
dessus c'est clairement une victoire
puisque en réalité
faire simple qu'est ce qui s'était passé
d'abord il y avait un accord sur un plan
pour aider les différents pays européens
dans le second de temps certain nombre
de pays européens ont dit oui mais il
faut des conditions sur ce fameux
respect de l'état de droit ou en réalité
on sait pas vraiment très précisément ce
que ça recoupe l'on peut tout y mettre à
jour c'est ça le véritable danger et à
la aujourd'hui clairement le plan
européen pour s'appliquer n'exige plus
ce respect de l'état de droit par la
pologne et par la hongrie et donc ceux
qui voulaient bloquer les subventions
pour ces deux pays
ou plutôt soumettre ses subventions à
une condition dès maintenant
eh bien on réellement perdu alors le
sommet européen qui va évidemment se
consacrer à la crise pandémique en
europe 1 malheureusement ça se passe mal
en europe l'europe qui accueille
désormais de montrer qu'elle avance
d'une même voix face au virus
contrairement à ce qu'elle avait fait
lors de la première vague c'est toujours
le rêve de dire qu'on avance d'une même
voix d'une même voix mais en réalité là
l'affrontement convient de voir entre
deux ou trois pays puisque je rappelle
que la slovénie soutenait aussi la
hongrie et la pologne et le reste des
pays européens montrent qu'il ya deux
conceptions durable au sein de l'union
européenne
c'est à dire ceux qui comme monsieur
macron par exemple madame merkel
souhaitent que petit à petit les états
s'efface au profit de l'union européenne
et ceux qui considèrent que l'union
européenne doit être avant tout un
regroupement de nations comme monsieur
viktor orban comme la pologne comme la
slovaque l'homme la slovaquie et je
rajoute aussi comme marine le pen et le
parti que nous représentons au parlement
européen et donc cette différence de
conception de la vision européenne elle
perdure alors la stratégie de
vaccination
qu'est ce que vous en attendez thierry
mariani est ce que l'europe sera à la
hauteur pour vous on voit le royaume uni
s'est beaucoup commenté qui a pris
longueur d'avancé le ministre de la
santé qui a même évoqué le break site en
dix ans et grâce aux breaks site votre
sentiment sur ce point écoutez d'abord
j'attends que il est absolument pas de
réglementation au niveau européen ce qui
serait totalement illégal pour imposer à
tous les pays
les mêmes mesures je crois qu'il faut
que chaque pays puisse choisir par
exemple au niveau français nous sommes
extrêmement attachés à ce que cette
vaccination soit sur la base du
volontariat et en aucun cas sur une base
obligatoire
ensuite on jugera quand la campagne sera
fini on a vu clients européenne à titre
préventif à acheter toute une série de
médicaments de vaccins
pendant dans certains n'étaient même pas
encore opérationnel on voit ce qui se
passe sur le même désir on verra ce qui
se passe sur d'autres médicaments c'est
un peu tôt pour juger au caire
évidemment des discussions de ce sommet
également le break site les négociations
toujours dans le brouillard sur les
futures relations commerciales entre
lieux et le royaume-uni forte
possibilité qu'il n'y ait pas d'accord
avec un lieu nous a dit boris johnson du
côté de la présidente de la commission
et bien c'est pareil je vous propose
d'écouter ursula von der leyen et le
troisième sujet sera certainement le
break si j'ai eu une très longue
conversation hier soir avec le premier
ministre boris johnson
c'était une bonne conversation mais
c'est difficile
nous sommes disposés à accorder l'accès
au marché unique à nos amis britanniques
c'est le plus grand marché unique du
monde mais les conditions doivent être
équitables elles doivent être équitables
pour nos travailleurs et nos entreprises
et cet équilibre d'équipé n'a pas été
atteint jusqu'à présent nos négociateurs
travaillent toujours et nous prendrons
une décision dimanche
voilà plutôt du pessimisme des deux
côtés je le rappelle forte possibilité
qu'il n'y ait pas d'accord avec lui
c'est ce qu'a dit boris johnson ce soir
c'est du bluff ou on est parti pour un
new deal
thierry mariani c'est trop tôt pour le
dire mais si je devais parier je pense
qu'il n'y aura pas d'accord je pense
qu'il n'y aura pas d'accord parce qu'on
a encore des différends fondamentaux nue
entre les européens et les britanniques
sur trois fois d'abord le premier c'est
la gouvernance et les moyens de régler
les différends futur c'est à dire quand
il y aura des accords entre la grande
bretagne et l'union européenne à qui on
va confier j'allais dire le jugement
c'est différent que demande l'union
européenne elle demande à ce que le
jugement de ces différents soit confiée
à la cour de justice de l'union
européenne
bien sûr les britanniques refusent parce
qu'il est évident que la cour de justice
de l'union européenne
et quand même fortement liée à l'union
européenne et donc les britanniques ne
veulent pas de ceux de ce cette instance
pour juger les différents
deuxième gros différent c'est ce qu'on
appelle le level playing field
c'est-à-dire en clair une garantie de
concurrence loyale ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire en clair que les européens et
là c'est une bonne condition que les
européens demandent à ce que les normes
qui ont été adoptés demeure par les
britanniques du temps où il était dans
l'union européenne demeure quoi qu'il
arrive c'est à dire en clair que si les
britanniques négocient un traité ce
conte ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
avec les états unis il n'y ait pas un
accord qui ensuite met notamment les
normes phytosanitaires ou les normes
sanitaires en dessous du niveau où elles
sont aujourd'hui en clair c'est un
accord qui dit on peut pas avoir des
conditions désormais plus favorables
pour toute une série de productions en
grande bretagne est donc là c'est une
les britanniques le refuse pour le
moment et je pense que l'union
européenne à la raison de tenir là
dessus et dernier point c'est la pêche
alors la pêche n'est pas énorme en terme
de volume mais c'est très important pour
les pêcheurs france
et puisqu'en moyenne les pêcheurs
français font 30% leur capture dans les
eaux territoriales britanniques
qu'est ce que demande l'union européenne
elle demande à ce qu'il ya un accord
pour des quotas de pêche puisqu'à
l'heure actuelle les britanniques par
exemple d'accord avec les norvégiens
vous savez que les norvégiens ne sont
pas dans l'union européenne et donc en
réalité il y aura un accord sur des
quotas de pêche mais les bruits les
britanniques veulent un accord annuel
l'union européenne va un accord sur dix
ans pour avoir une certaine visibilité
et donc là visiblement il n'y a toujours
pas d'accord mais soyons clair l'union
européenne a aussi un moyen de de
rétorsion c'est que n'oublions pas que
les produits de la pêche britannique
péché par les pêcheurs britannique ce
land aussi sur le territoire européen et
donc sur ces trois points
aujourd'hui il ya un désaccord on ne
parle plus de l'irlande puisque
visiblement d'accord a été de trouver
rapidement jeu sur le break 6 à ce jour
mais aussi vous avoir votre sentiment
sur sur la turquie mais vous craignez
vous clairement des conséquences d'un
odile non sincèrement non il y aura
quelques complications administratives
on voit par exemple les fils de poids
lourds qui s'allonge mais non je pense
que si un audi l'a écouté il ya plein de
pays avec lesquels on n'a pas d'accord
avec l'union européenne
c'est dans la logique de boris johnson
ils voulaient le break site il peut pas
à la fois quitté l'europe et avoir un
accord qui le lie totalement aux mêmes
conditions que d'autres pays avec
l'europe
donc ça me surprend pas dernier dossier
très en vue lors de ce sommet européen
la turquie avec la question des
sanctions que contre ankara la france
sera bien seul sur ce dossier la france
une fois de plus ses draps l'allemagne
c'est à dire qu'on sait très bien que la
chancelière est très on va dire
favorables relations avec la turquie
et on voit qu'à chaque fois et bien
c'est cette position qui l'emportent
voilà je vous rappelle quand même que la
france par exemple vous voulez quelques
sanctions contre la turquie elle a
aucune
il n'y a aucune la turquie ne respectent
rien je vous rappelle qu encore des
journalistes il ya peu de temps sont
décédées dans les prisons de turquie
pour des grèves de la faim au temps
j'allais dire lui
européenne est forte avec les faibles on
voit par exemple les sanctions qu'on
applique sur le belarus autant la
turquie est faible avec les forts il ya
aucune sanction il ya des discussions il
ya des des reproches faits à la turquie
est un dernier exemple pour montrer bien
la position allemande quand la france a
demandé le boycott des désarmements sur
la turquie l'allemagne s'y opposer et on
constate que l'allemagne continue à
vendre des armes la turquie donc
monsieur erdogan peut dormir sur ds et
ses oreilles sans aucun problème il a
une alliée dans la place avec madame
merkel merci thierry mariani député
européen du rassemblement national
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour commenter donc ce sommet
européen actuellement à bruxelles merci
à vous dans quelques instants on rester
avec nous reviendrons sur la pénurie de
masse au printemps dernier la commission
d'enquêté du sénat pointe la
responsabilité de jérôme salomon dans un
rapport rendu public aujourd'hui la
direction générale de la santé qui
dément et puis nous parlerons de l'essor
du télétravail véritable progrès ou
danger pour les salariés jacques sapir
tentera d'y répondre
[Musique]
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique
ça fait quand même beaucoup tout ça le
fondement la politique c'est la rumeur
ont réagi à des rumeurs et plus qu'à des
réalités ça comme conséquence que la
politique est devenue un métier du
spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique trop de lois tuent la loi et
les lois inutiles culé vol nwa
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film à
projets un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
d'être maintenant c'est l'industrie qui
gagne mais du coup peut-être que ce qui
va rester c'est que les films qui seront
de plus en plus fait pour le cinéma et
pas sur les grands réseaux resteront des
objets artistiques setting godard qui
disait cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma on lève
les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous de
cecco politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la veille d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient des
lignes aujourd'hui une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview ya pas une
façon plus une pauvre de défendre un
système que de dire qu'il est moins pire
qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï pg les gens
ne s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui le droit on doit éviter les
dérives idéologiques merci de le
souligner comment peut-on reconstituer
une sixième république qui ne soit pas
une république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
merci de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
est ce que la ville dense et mortifère
ce n'est pas la dent fip et brûle c'est
à dire le rapport entre la population un
territoire qui est porteur de causalité
d'explications mais des densités un
grand filon du département il ya des
chaînes de contagion du se font à
l'intérieur rassemblement du milieu
familial parce que on a des familles qui
vivent à trois générations et c'est tout
cet ensemble de causes qui
constitutionnellement un syndrome en
quelque sorte social et dont le colis
est à la fois le révélateur est
malheureusement la cause déterminante
ponctuelles je suis très frappé entre
eux présentant des sciences sociales par
finalement le progrès considérables
comme à fait dans cette endémie
tellement dérivation n'a pas que des
mauvais côtés en un an on a mis au point
pratiquement avec
[Musique]
21h heure française merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 10 décembre jean castex serre
la vis nous ne pouvons pas baisser la
garde à partir de mardi couvre-feu
strict instauré à partir de 20 heures
il concernera la soirée de la saint
sylvestre mais pas celle du 24 décembre
les musées théâtres et cinémas devront
patienter encore côté allègement plus
des stations nécessaire en journée et
déplacements de nouveau autorisée
partout en france
jérôme c'est le mans lui est dans le
viseur du scénario serait responsable de
la pénurie de masques et même accusé
d'avoir fait pression pour empêcher la
publication d'un rapport la direction
générale de la santé démentent ce soir
le premier ministre qui a aussi
encouragé largement le recours au
télétravail déjà permis par la loi il
s'installe encore davantage dans nos
vies professionnelle et privée après
avoir suscité l'enthousiasmé d'une
partie des salariés lors du premier
confinement beaucoup pointent
aujourd'hui ses inconvénients
alors le télétravail véritable progrès
ou danger pour les salariés l'abus de
télétravail nuit-il à la santé autant de
questions auxquelles l'économiste
jacques sapir tentera de répondre tout à
l'heure dans son édito
outre-atlantique le fils de joe biden
sous le coup d'une enquête fédérale sur
sa situation fiscale
si la victoire du démocrate à la
présidentielle est validée donald trump
lui joue son va tout dans un recours
post électorale déposé par le texas
devant la cour suprême sur le front de
la pandémie rebond spectaculaire du
virus dans le pays les données du vaccin
des laboratoires pfizer bio ntech sont
examinées aujourd'hui par des experts
indépendants et pourrait ainsi être
autorisé dans les prochains jours et
puis au liban premières inculpations
d'hommes politiques annoncées quatre
mois après l'explosion du port de
beyrouth
l'ex-chef du gouvernement hassan diab et
trois de ses ex ministres accusés de
négligence et d'avoir causé des décès
c'est la première fois qu'un premier
ministre en exercice est inculpé dans le
cadre de ses fonctions au pays du cèdre
[Musique]
jean castex a donc tenu une conférence
de presse tout à l'heure sur la
situation sanitaire et a fait le point
sur la phase suivante avec la fin du
confinement prévue le 15 décembre et
précision de notre reporter nadège
abderrazak avenue de ségur
alors comme prévu le déconfinement aura
bel et bien lieu le 15 décembre mais
avec le maintien des restrictions
sanitaires le déconfinement va donc
laisser place à un couvre feu nocturne
de 20 heures à 6 heures du matin un
couvre-feu qui sera strictement contrôlé
à en croire jean castex le ministre de
l'intérieur et gérald darmanin qui
accompagnait le premier ministre
aujourd'hui lors de ce point presse et
bien a prévenu que le non respect de ce
couvre feu sera puni d'une amende de 135
euros s'en sera fini également de
l'attestation en journée puisque lé
déplacement seront autorisées partout en
france a noté également la fermeture
pour au moins trois semaines
supplémentaires et des lieux de
rassemblement cinéma théâtre ou encore
salle de spectacle on écoute justement
jean castex à ce sujet mais les règles
seront plus stricts que ceux que nous
avions initialement envisagé première
décision
les établissements recevant du public
dont nous avions prévu la réouverture au
15 décembre resteront fermées trois
semaines de plus les conditions posées
pour leur réouverture ne sont hélas pas
réunies il s'agit principalement des
cinémas des théâtres les salles de
spectacles des musées mais aussi de
l'accueil du public dans les enceintes
sportives dans les cirques des parcs
zoologiques ou encore les salles de jeux
et quasi cela signifie également que les
règles posées récemment pour les lieux
de culte ne seront pas revus à la hausse
qu'en est il des fêtes de fin d'année
pourra-t-on les célébrer en famille ça
sera oui pour noël non pour le réveillon
du jour de l'an le couvre feu sera donc
maintenus pour la soirée de la saint
sylvestre avec cette recommandation pas
plus de six personnes à table
en revanche on aurait pu penser que
cette mesure soit aussi appliqué pour
noël jean castex dit non pourquoi et
bien parce que noël tient une place
importante dit-il dans nos vies dans nos
traditions alors le couvre-feu sera donc
levé pour le 24 décembre pas besoin
d'attestation pour se déplacer à des
mesures qui peuvent paraître difficiles
voire incompréhensible mais justifié un
qualifié de nécessaire par le premier
ministre pour justement éviter une
éventuelle troisième vague de l'épidémie
nous savons que les fêtes de fin d'année
à noël ou pour le nouvel an constituent
des moments particulièrement à risque
le retour d'expérience ce qui s'est
passé aux états unis ou au canada pour
les fêtes de thanksgiving le démontre
amplement puisque chaque fois c'est fait
ont entraîné une accélération de
l'épidémie
pour toutes ces raisons nous ne pouvons
pas baisser la garde
nous devons rester cohérent et négocier
les prochaines semaines avec beaucoup de
vigilance
nous devons adapter nos mesures autour
d'un objectif
permettre à chacune et chacun de
profiter des vacances et des fêtes de
fin d'année mais sans nous exposer un
risque de rebond de l'épidémie ni
maintenant ni dans les premières
semaines de janvier car je pense que
nous serons tous d'accord sur ce point
faisons tout ce que nous pouvons pour
réduire le risque de devoir vivre un
troisième confinement dans les prochains
mois c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
sous l'autorité du président de la
république d'adapter la stratégie de
déconfinement en pleine cohérence avec
ceux qui vous avait été présentée le 24
novembre dernier déconfinement au 15
décembre et instauration d'un couvre-feu
nocturne voilà ce que l'on pouvait
retenir ce soir de ce point presse de
jean castex le premier ministre qui
était donc accompagné à l'occasion de
son ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
et de gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur aucune pression n'a été
exercée pour modifier un rapport
d'expert réponse de la direction
générale de la santé aux accusations des
commissions du sénat contre jérôme
salomon en cause la pénurie de masques
les détails et explications avec bath
and chips un échange d'e-mails qui ne
fait pas les affaires de l'exécutif
encore moins celle de jérôme salomon le
directeur général de la santé au coeur
de la polémique et des e-mails que la
commission d' enquête du sénat a pu se
procurer
selon nos confrères du journal le monde
des messages de jérôme salomon pour
faire pression sur la rédaction du
rapport ce talent commandé par l' agence
santé publique france sur la situation
sanitaire française remis en 2018 ce
rapport indiquait au gouvernement la
nécessité de provisionner un milliard de
masques afin d'être en mesure de faire
face à une éventuelle crise sanitaire
il est important qu'une doctrine soit
rapidement établie par vos services pour
que les éventuelles acquisitions de
produits de santé soient mises en oeuvre
afin de disposer d'un stock avant le
deuxième trimestre 2010 9
sauf que ce rapport n'arrange pas à
l'époque les affaires du ministère de la
santé
soucieux de faire des économies en
témoigne l'achat d'un stock en 2018 par
le directeur général de la santé de
l'époque benoît valait nettement
inférieure aux recommandations des
experts
100 millions de masques seulement
à peine 10% du milliards préconisés
aujourd'hui ce rapport ce talent qui
avertissait des conséquences éventuelles
d'une crise sanitaire est une épine dans
le pied du gouvernement
car loin de tenir compte des
recommandations du rapport l'exécutif
s'est au contraire échiné à en atténuer
la portée
c'est ainsi que jérôme salomon aurait
tenté par des e-mails de contraindre
l'ex directeur de santé publique france
à minimiser les risques
l'une des solutions pourrait être alors
de modifier la rédaction de certaines
formulations
ensuite il reviendra aux autorités de
définir le stock nécessaire une pression
trop lourde à supporter pour françois
bourdillon qui finira par céder
quelques temps après voilà donc en
retour la vie dans lequel j'ai retiré
toute allusion à un stock chiffres et
notamment pour les masques les 7 et 8
décembre dernier les sénateurs ont eu
accès aux conclusions de la commission
denquête et ses dernières établissait
clairement les pressions exercées par
jérôme salomon pour modifier l'avis
remis en août 2010 8 à santé publique
france cette politique de réduction des
coûts à tout prix même celui de la santé
des français ne date pas d'hier
car benoît vallet directeur général de
la santé de 2013 à 2018 en avait déjà
fait les frais face à la destruction
d'une partie des stocks de masques et
jugé non conforme
le prédécesseur de jérôme salomon avait
cessé de mettre en garde l'exécutif
visiblement plus conciliant son
successeur ex conseiller santé des
manuels macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle
était-il au courant du risque de pénurie
de masques en cas de crise là encore la
réponse serait oui si l'on en croit une
note confidentielle datée du 5 septembre
2016 est adressé aux candidats emmanuel
macron la possibilité de survenue d'un
événement naturels d'ampleur avec un
impact sur grand nombre de personnes des
dommages matériels importants
un impact financier et d'image et des
capacités de réaction des passes et doit
être sérieusement envisagée est
anticipée la france n'est pas prête
notre pays doit adapter ses
organisations aux spécificités des
crises majeures à venir des
recommandations adressées par jérôme
salomon médecins aux candidats macron
des recommandations donc que jérôme
salomon devenu directeur général de la
santé n'a pas vraiment pris en compte
un revirement difficile à comprendre
au final dans l'esprit de beaucoup ce
rapport viendra confirmer le sentiment
d' incohérences total de l'exécutif dans
la gestion de ces fameux masque car
après en avoir considérablement diminuer
le stock
il a longtemps nié leur utilité avant de
les rendre obligatoires avec amende à la
clef pour les contrevenants face à la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
ainsi que celle du sénat l'étau se
resserre sur un gouvernement qui semble
avoir épuisé son stock d' excuses quant
à sa gestion très discutable de la crise
sanitaire et pour en parler nous avons
avec fabrice di vizio avocat en droit de
la santé publique bonsoir fabrice di
vizio merci d'être avec nous la
responsabilité donc de jérôme salle au
monde sur la pénurie de masques pointé
du doigt par les sénateurs c'est
désormais jérôme salomon qui va
cristalliser une fonte une
responsabilité dans la gestion de cette
crise et en particulier la gestion des
masques je sais pas si jérôme c'est le
monde va cristalliser une responsabilité
mais jérôme salomon a une responsabilité
et jérôme seulement à 2 responsabilité
d'avoir fait pression sur santé publique
france et d'avoir menti devant la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale en
excipant d'un rapport qu'il savait être
inexact puisque c'est lui qui l'avait
fait changer c'est à dire que à un
moment vous avez affaire à quelqu'un qui
de bout en bout
finalement un vraiment jouer un rôle
catastrophique dans cette crise et si on
en est là
nul doute que c'est en grande partie à
cause de lui quel est le pire pour vous
mettre division vous venez dire la
responsabilité dans la gestion des
stocks et d'une certaine manière la
dissimulation le mensonge quel est le
pire pour l'avocate vous êtes juriste
que vous êtes le juriste que je suis a
envoyé aujourd'hui deux courriers l'un
au juge d'instruction en charge du
dossier
le deuxième à la commission
d'instruction de la cour de shiso
république en demandant à ce que
monsieur soit lhomond soient auditionnés
et au juge d'instruction en ajoutant que
la question de sa mise en examen pour
témoignage doit se poser ça c'est ça
c'est le juriste le juriste il fait du
droit et le droit ici nécessite que l'on
sache ce qui s'est exactement passé et
comment qualifiés pénalement
cette pression exercée sur santé
publique france et pourquoi santé
publique france à accepter cette
pression tandis que dans l'autre et bien
mentir devant une commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale
ça constitue encore une infraction est
donc le plus grave dans tout ça c'est
quoi
eh ben le plus grave je vais vous dire
ce que c'est que le plus grand le plus
grave c'est qu'il ya cinquante mille
morts voilà ce que c'est que le plus
grand le plus grave c'est que pendant
que ces gens font une espèce d'entre eux
soient littéraires lorsque on joue sur
les mots on joue sur les concepts est
bien la vérité c'est qu'ils avaient pas
de masquer la vérité c'est que des
soignants sont allés au front et sont
morts
la vérité c'est que les populations
n'ont pas pu être protégées c'est ça qui
est le plus grave alors ce qui est
étonnant on l'a vu dans le reportage de
bassem chemise c'est finalement jérôme
sainement et aient assez lucide il avait
alerté le candidat macron sur une
éventuelle pandémie que la france
n'était pas prête il est devenu ensuite
directeur général de la santé et là il
ya eu cette attitude semble-t-il qu'est
ce que ça dit du système
sadi de ce système je vais employer un
mot dur qu'il est pourri jusqu'à la
moelle
donc ce système il est gangréné ça
prouve que la politique a raison de tout
quand je vous dis depuis le premier jour
que tout a été politique dans cette
crise que tout à été communication dans
cette crise c'est ça que je voulais dire
et j'en ai bien la preuve encore
aujourd'hui j'ai été un prophète eut
désole un jeudi un musée de la province
et la prophétie qu'appliquer facile
puisque tout le monde le sait mais quand
je vous dis que la problématique de ce
pays c'est que la politique gangrène
tout c'est c'est la manifestation
tangible
il la conscience du danger
il a conscience de jouer avec la vie des
gens mais à un moment la raison
politique
la raison d'économie politique est bien
à raison de tout précisément
et j'ajoute et vous me demandiez ce
qu'est le plus grave et après je dois
faire confiance à un homme que je vois
là sur vos images pour me vendre un
vaccin
je dois faire confiance à celui ci là
pour venir me vacciner et m'expliquer
les yeux dans les yeux que je ne crains
rien lorsqu'il me vaccine mais de qui
est ce qu'on se moque bien sûr que j'ai
pas confiance en lui
bien sûr que n'importe quel citoyen un
tout petit peu éveillées ne pourrait
plus jamais avoir confiance en jérôme
salomon et que dès lors la seule
question qui se pose c'est est-ce que
jérôme seulement va être couvert par son
ministre de tutelle
ou est-ce que jérôme seulement va être
lâché par son ministre de tutelle car
semble-t-il m division je parle souvent
de contrôle mais le rapport dit que
jérôme seulement étaient en réalité
informé de la situation des stocks en
2018 il a pourtant décidé de ne pas
reconstituer ses stocks et surtout de ne
pas en informer la ministre de tutelle l
époque agnès buzyn ensuite remplacé par
olivier veron est ce que d'une certaine
manière ça des douanes
agnès buzyn à ma connaissance vous
poursuivez aussi pour sa gestion de la
crise tout comme olivier merlin alors
guebuza avait dit quelque chose si vous
vous souvenez avait dit ces choses là ne
remonte pas au ministre en parlant de
des stocks de masques en fait entre
autres enfin les stocks de produits en
général et on voit qu'elle avait raison
finalement ça ne remonte pas au ministre
alors ça veut dire que jérôme salomon
quand je vous disais également que ce
pays est administré les pas gouverner
vous en avez encore la preuve manifeste
tous les maux de ce système sont
cristallisés dans la personne de jérôme
salomon jérôme seulement aux
administrateurs et on a laissé ce pays
être administrés et pas de gouverner ça
des douanes le ministre m'a donc ça le
dédouane pas parce que le patron de
jérôme salle mancelle ministre celui qui
est nommé à la fonction de gouvernement
et qui assurent le gouvernement de la
cité en particulier en matière de santé
c'est le ministre jérôme salomon
pardonner
le dire comme ça c'est un second couteau
sauf que c'est un second couteau qui a
pris la place du ministre il est calife
à la place du calife
et on l'a laissé faire aujourd'hui quels
sont les enseignements à tirer
rapidement de cette affaire et que doit
devenir jérôme salomon que risque-t-il
jérôme salomon ce qu'il doit devenir je
ne sais pas ce qui doit faire c'est
démissionner si jérôme salomon reste
aujourd'hui directeur général de la
santé ça veut donc dire concrètement que
l'on peut mentir et une commission
denquête on peut mettre les populations
en danger
on peut administrer dans le dos d'un
ministre et ce sans aucune conséquence
est bien la seule conséquence que ça
aura si jérôme salomon reste en poste
c'est que les français aient bien
n'auront plus confiance dans le
gouvernement et à une crise sanitaire
succédera une crise politique et
institutionnelle inégalée dans
l'histoire de la république
merci beaucoup fabrique sa division
avocat en droit de la santé un public
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et ce soir dans son allocution
jean castex à nouveau encouragé le
télétravail mis en place dès le 1er
confinement est déjà autorisé par la loi
il s'installe le télétravail encore plus
dans nos vies professionnelle et privée
il a d'abord provoqué l'enthousiasmé
beaucoup pointent aujourd'hui ses
inconvénients
alors le télétravail véritable progrès
ou bien danger pour les salariés la
butte télétravail nuit-il à la santé on
en parle tout de suite avec un autre
économiste jacques sapir bonsoir jacques
bonsoir c'est fini alors c'est donc une
des conséquences de la crise sanitaire
un l'essor de ce télétravail pas trop
malheureux de devoir télé travailler
avec nous d'ailleurs jacques ça vous
concerne derrière votre ficus devenue
célèbre souris bercy peu cool n'auront
pas je prends mon mal en patience
alors oui vous avez tout à fait raison
le que vides lakovic 19 n'a pas créé le
télétravail mais elle a
incontestablement contribué à leur
répondre de manière à tout à fait
considérable ainsi il y avait 4 % des
salariés qui avaient recours au
télétravail
avant la crise sanitaire
et il y en a eu pratiquement 1 sur 4
pendant le premier confinement alors au
départ ce qui est intéressant c'est que
pratiquement les trois quarts des
français qui étaient en télétravail été
très heureux de le faire dans le cadre
disait que cela leur convenait bien et
c'était la même chose du point de vue
des entreprises
si vous voulez les entreprises voyaient
que le télétravail pouvait être
l'occasion pour elle de réduire leur
loyer prévu après le fantasme de lusine
cents ouvriers et bien on avait le
fantasme de l'entreprise de bureaux sans
bureaux alors on définitif ce
télétravail qui concerne t-il alors vous
avez tout à fait raison de poser cette
question et c'est un des premiers
problèmes auxquels on est confrontés en
réalité on voit que le télétravail
il est extrêmement concentré sur
certaines régions on le voit par exemple
pour le premier confinement alors que
vous l'aurez je vous le redis la moyenne
des travailleurs s'étaient 24 % des
travailleurs qui étaient en télétravail
or qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit qu'ils
étaient 44% dans la région ile de france
c'est tout à fait considérable
al'inverse ils sont évidemment beaucoup
moins nombreux dans d'autres régions
comme les pays de loire les hauts de
france ou la normandie
donc ça prouve qu'il y a une très grande
disparité entre régions sur cette
question du télétravail alors il est
clair jacques que toutes les professions
ne se prête pas de la même manière on en
sait quelque chose au télétravail
oui c'est une évidence on comprend bien
que le télétravail n'a pas vraiment sa
place dans l'industrie dans le bâtiment
est évidemment dans la construction bon
mais il n'a pas non plus sa place dans
des professions qui implique un contact
personnel par exemple ou une présence
physique le cas des transports
évidemment mais aussi le cas de
l'agriculture voire du commerce de
proximité
en fait ce sont essentiellement les
travailleurs du tertiaire qui sont
conservés alors il n'y a t'il jacques un
lien entre la taille de l'entreprise et
l'importance du télétravail oui tout à
fait c'est quelque chose que l'on a
remarqué alors même si c'est de manière
un petit point direct on a vu
effectivement que le télétravail se
développe et surtout dans des
entreprises de taille moyenne ou de
petite taille
alors quand je dis que c'est un un
indicateur induits c'est que on a un
consulter un petit peu des statistiques
qui regardent la demande en nouveaux
outils numériques par exemple les
logiciels de téléconférence et bien ce
qu'on a vu c'est que le nombre de
travailleurs qui ont eu besoin de
s'équiper avec ces nouveaux outils et
les effectivement beaucoup plus
important dans les entreprises disons de
taille moyenne entre 250 et 1000 et
émile salariés alors qu'est ce que ça
nous donne ça nous donne un portrait
type en fait un du télétravailleur 1
c'est une femme ou un homme travaillant
dans le tertiaire
employé dans une entreprise plutôt de
taille moyenne de plusieurs dizaines
voire de plusieurs centaines de
personnes et résidant essentiellement ou
en région parisienne ou dans une grande
métropole comme lyon marseille ou
strasbourg
alors la question quels avantages trouvé
ton au télétravail lors de ce premier
confinement là aussi c'est un point
intéressant c'est qu'il ya eu des
plusieurs études lui disait une enfance
des études internationales
et qu'est ce qu'on va en voir que de ce
point de vue là les travailleurs eux ils
voyaient dans le télétravail tout
d'abord une manière je dirais
d'améliorer la gestion de leurs horaires
ou de pouvoir avoir un cadre travail de
travail plus agréable que le bureau par
exemple pour les entreprises c'était
plutôt les avantages qui concernait la
réduction des dépenses quotidiennes pour
l'entreprise voit un accroissement
apparent de la productivité seulement
avec la fin du premier confinement les
opinions ont commencé à se réajuster ça
c'est un poids qui est extrêmement
intéressant en fait au début du mois
d'octobre dernier et au moment où on a
commencé à se reposer la question d'un
possible confinement eh bien on s'est
aperçu que le nombre de travailleurs qui
étaient dans lé travail et des as et de
24 % à 14 %
donc en fait seulement 4 % avaient
recours de manière intégrale
il ya cinq jours par semaine au
télétravail il y avait donc eu un recul
très net de ce que le premier ministre
jean castex avait un peu imprudemment
qualifié de phénomène de société ou de
révolution dans la manière de travailler
et pourquoi ce changement alors il tout
récent de regarder les raisons qui ont
amené les entreprises à prendre un peu
de distance justement avec cette
question du télétravail a tout d'abord
les responsables se sont mis à craindre
que malgré des systèmes informatiques
intrusif qui sont parfois utilisés de ne
pas pouvoir contrôler leurs salariés
vous savez ce n'est pas un hasard si les
open space se sont multipliées dans les
bureaux depuis une vingtaine d'années
les open space
ils ont pour fonction d'organiser le
contrôle sur les salariés
après les entreprises se sont rendus
compte que avec le télétravail
elle permet cette capacité qu'avait
leurs salariés de se rencontrer
d'échanger des idées de pouvoir même
cédé pour effectuer certaines tâches à
fait
les entreprises ont réalisé que le
télétravail pourrait aussi avoir des
conséquences néfastes à la fois sur
l'innovation et sur la productivité des
salariés
alors on comprend effectivement alors
pourquoi les entreprises à son sont plus
de rentes sont présentes mais n'y at il
pas aussi des réticences du côté des
salariés
oui oui vous avez tout à fait raison
stéphanie en fait on voit qu'il y à
plusieurs risques qui sont apparus pour
les salariés avec cette extension du
télétravail
premier risque évidemment c'est le
risque d'isolement social c'est aussi le
risque est lié au fait que le
télétravail fait disparaître la
frontière entre la vie professionnelle
et la vie privée du salarié
et puis il ya ensuite l'ensemble des
risques qui sont induits par là la
pression sur le salarié lié aux
objectifs des objectifs qui d'ailleurs
ne peuvent plus être discuté aussi
facilement qu'au bureau enfin ça semble
assez évident mais visiblement les gens
l'ont redécouvert il ya tous les
problèmes matériels
lié à l'équipement informatique du
travailleur lié aussi à l'espace dont on
dispose de chez soi pour pouvoir
travailler
il est clair que ces conditions
matérielles joue beaucoup aujourd'hui
dans le ressenti par rapport au
télétravail et pourtant ces questions
ont fait l'objet d'un accord récent oui
tout à fait tout est fait c'est fini ces
problèmes ont eu un début de
reconnaissance avec l'accord qui a été
signé le 27 novembre dernier entre les
organisations patronales et des
organisations syndicales sam accord qui
vise en particulier à prévenir le
harcèlement du salarié par son employeur
mais cet accord n'est en fait que le
début de la reconnaissance des problèmes
liés au télétravail
donc il faudra aller nettement plus loin
et puis et puis il ya quand même un gros
problème c'est qu'il faut le savoir les
les problèmes qui sont liées justement
au télétravail
eh bien il donne à 10 ans il donne
naissance à une interrogation quant à la
santé des travailleurs
et pourquoi ces interrogations alors là
encore c'est une chose intéressante et
où on peut croiser des données qui
viennent d'études canadiennes d'études
qui ont été faites sur la france on voit
très bien qu'il ya eu des problèmes
alors entre ce que j'avais cité comme l'
isolement où le chevauchement entre la
vie privée et la vie professionnelle
il ya aussi la montée des tensions au
sein des équipes
une fois que son passé en télétravail
pourquoi parce que on s'est rendu compte
que la communication par voix d'écran
favorise justement cette montée des
conflits par yann étudier des fêtes
parra cabinet d'expertisé français le
cabinet syndex qui montrait d'ailleurs
que la crise avait amplifié le risque
s'il est psychologique et risques
psychosociaux dans les entreprises il ya
aussi le risque de montée des addictions
en tous genres alcool cigarette c'est
mon devoir a d'ailleurs rattaché à cela
la montée qui est assez effrayante de la
consommation de psychotropes que l'on
constate d'ailleurs depuis ces dernières
semaines alors tout ceci n'a de tous
ceux ci portent un nom ça s'appelle la
désocialisation des personnes
en situation de télétravail et on a
tendance quand même l oublier le travail
en présentiel si vous voulez le fait
d'aller sur son lieu de travail
justement
et bien c'est un facteur majeur dans la
socialisation des individus
donc en gros le télétravail n'est pas
bon pour la santé jacques et don et non
et c'est que quelque chose d'autre à se
rendre compte lors en même temps il faut
bien mesurer les paradoxes du
télétravail pour des personnes qui ont
un niveau d'éducation très élevés qui
sont dans le bonne condition qu'ils font
un travail intéressant par exemple le
basculement vers le télétravail a été à
l'évidence une opportunité fructueuse de
même pour certaines entreprises dont les
entreprises ou les tâches sont des
tâches qui sont essentiellement des
tâches innovante et qui peuvent faire
confiance justement à leurs salariés
de ce point de vue là et bien
effectivement le télétravail a pu être
aussi une bonne opportunité pour la
majorité des travailleurs du tertiaire
comme pour la majorité des entreprises
concernées et bien le télétravail
s'avère être un piège et il faudra donc
certainement à l'avenir
encadrées et limitées très probablement
cette pratique
alors oui pour répondre à votre question
le télétravail et bien non ce n'est pas
bon pour la santé
et cela peut conduire justement à cette
fameuse désocialisation d'une grande
partie des personnes concernées et bien
jacques dans ce cas prenez soin de vous
puisque vous êtes en télé travail et
merci pour cet éclairage à la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup c'est avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons
des états unis alors que donald trump
abat ses dernières cartes pour contester
les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle
[Musique]
après avoir affronté une première puis
une deuxième vague de kovy 19 le pays
va-t-il devoir faire face à une vague de
licenciements on a vraiment un problème
de chômage et qui va être explosif
n'en doutez pas un seul instant à cause
de ce capitalisme très financiarisé il
ya une précarité de l'emploi vous coudes
et des plans sociaux étaient déjà prévus
depuis longtemps et le cog hill ne sert
juste que de prétexte au salon nous
approcher cette année saint d'autre de
la barre fatidique des 10 millions de
chômeurs ces destructions de postes
auraient pu être évitées par exemple
s'ils ont lavé conditionner les aides
mises en place par le gouvernement dans
une chaise il ya toujours ceux qui
trinquent et ceux qui en profitent alors
on voit bien que les actionnaires sont
totalement épargnée et tout ça est géré
je vous dis pas de la pire des façons
depuis des années ça n'est pas venu
simplement avec la crise yeux vides
[Musique]
21 30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus si vous nous rejoignez après
le royaume-uni bahreïn le canada devient
le troisième pays au monde a approuvé le
vaccin de l'alliance pfizer bio ntech le
pays avec qui compte 38 millions
d'habitants a d'ores et déjà commandé 20
millions de doses d'ici la fin 2021 plus
56 millions en option mais les effets
secondaires de ce vaccin nouvelle
génération font déjà débat tu es au
combat c'est un vaccin qui donne la
fièvre mais pas celle du samedi soir
il a pourtant déjà été commandés par des
dizaines de pays
le vaccin élaboré par l'alliance
américano allemand de kaysersberg tech
suscite de nombreuses interrogations
élaboré à partir d'une méthode jamais
commercialisée auparavant
le produit a été validée en un temps
record par les autorités sanitaires de
trois pays
la campagne de vaccination a commencé ce
mardi 8 décembre au royaume uni et
débutera très prochainement à bahreïn et
au canada et pour ottawa les bénéfices
dépassent largement les risques lorsque
nous accordons une autorisation
cela signifie que nous l'avons examiné
que les bénéfices l'emportent sur les
risques potentiels mais cela reste un
médicament un vaccin et il existe des
risques potentiels même s'ils sont rares
c'est donc pour cela qu'il est important
que nous continuions de le surveiller
je dirais donc aux canadiens que nous
l'avons autorisé si c'est à leur tour de
se faire vacciner
ils doivent se sentir à l'aise à l'idée
de le faire des risques d'effets
secondaires sérieux qui semble pourtant
bien réelle seulement 24 heures après le
début de la vaccination le royaume uni
par l'intermédiaire de son agence du
médicament a déconseillé de
l'administrer aux personnes âgées sujet
à d'importantes réactions allergiques
une annonce faite après une mauvaise
réaction de deux personnes aux premières
injections des doutes sur la dangerosité
du vaccin que partage le chef du service
d'infectiologie de la pitié salpêtrière
eric comme je n'ai jamais vu une
fréquence aussi élevé d'effets
indésirables pour un vaccin
prenons l'exemple de la fièvre elle peut
survenir de manière passagère après une
injection c'est classique mais là 15,8
pour cent des 18 55 ans on tue 38 degrés
ou plus dans les sept jours qui ont
suivi la seconde injection et 45% ont dû
prendre un médicament contre la fièvre
ou la douleur
on parle aussi de 55% de maux de tête
62% de fatigue
une inquiétude que partage d'autres pays
les états unis vont par exemple réunir
une vingtaine d'experts ce jeudi pour
examiner les données sur le vaccin du
duo américano allemand une réunion
retransmise en direct sur internet pour
un exercice de transparence inédit
l'enjeu est énorme de nombreux médecins
dont le professeur comme craignent qu'en
cas d'échec les vaccins soit discrédité
pour longtemps auprès d'une population
qui semble déjà réfractaires à toujours
aux états unis 17 et apportent leur
soutien au texas dans un nouveau recours
devant la cour suprême visant à annuler
la défaite électorale de donald trump la
plante du texas concerne la pennsylvanie
le michigan hors exceptionnels la
géorgie soit près de 20 millions de
votes
une tentative de la dernière chance pour
le milliardaire américain tout comme la
précédente rejetée lundi par la cour
suprême
mais selon les experts elle n'a que peu
de chances d'aboutir
et en attendant de son côté joe biden a
présenté lui officiellement son candidat
pour le poste de chef du pentagone lloyd
austin c'est son nom dont il a évoqué le
nom débute semaine ce serait une
première pour un afro américain
il s'agit d'un ancien général qui
supervisait des troupes américaines
déployées au moyen-orient pendant le
mandat de barack obama
un choix contesté par une partie des
démocrates qui aurait préféré un civil
une option qui doit encore être validé
par le congrès s exprimant depuis 8000
tonnes dans l'état du delaware le
président élu a décrit cet homme de 67
ans comme la personne dont le pays avait
besoin en ce moment écoutez à leur
intervention à tous les deux il n'y a
aucun doute dans mon esprit
aucun doute du tout que ce candidat
honorera respectera et au quotidien
donnera vie aux principes prééminent du
leadership civile sur les questions
militaires dans notre nation
je connais cet homme je connais son
respect pour notre constitution
je sais qu'ils les respectent notre
système de gouvernement donc tout comme
ils l'ont fait pour le secrétaire jean
mathis le demande au congrès d'accorder
une dérogation pour le secrétaire
désigné austin
lorsque j'ai terminé mon service
militaire il ya quatre ans j'ai
raccroché mon uniforme pour la dernière
fois et je suis passé du statut de
général made d'austin à celui de lloyd
austin
c'est une distinction importante que je
fais avec sérieux et sincérité
et c'est ainsi que j'en suis arrivé à ce
rôle ce nouveau rôle de dirigeants
civils et le fils de joe biden est sous
le coup d'une enquête fédérale cela
concerne sa situation fiscale
hunter biden l'a lui-même annoncé hier
soir il est visé par une enquête
fédérale dans l'état du delaware le fils
de joe biden qui a été maintes fois
attaqué par l'administration tram
pendant la campagne électorale
donald trump avait qualifié la famille
byden des jo site une entreprise
criminelle
interbev n'avait été
en mise en cause pour ses affaires en
ukraine et en chine au moment où son
père était vice-président de barack
obama
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec douglas gates professeur de droit
spécialiste science politique américaine
bonsoir douglas yates merci d'être avec
nous hunter à bayonne qui est donc visé
par une enquête fédérale est ce que cela
peut avoir une incidence sur l'élection
de son père joe biden est devenu ce
qu'on appelle l'enfant terrible de
présidente élue mais il ne va pas jouer
sur l'élection
mais à la longue comme un fils en
berçant peuvent causer disons-le oui au
président démocrate
oui quand vous dites n'est pas causer
des ennuis c'est à dire ouais maintenant
le l'administration trempe à cibler même
avant la campagne présidentielle
vous vous souvenez de la un pitch mais
le président d'un clan
c'est le cause de tout ça c'est
l'investigation en ukraine des activités
de rentrer brydon qui étaient six à
siéger sur le conseil d'administration
d'une société ukrainienne qui s'appelle
boris mans est bon il y a plein des
choses dont l'un des vers de terre dans
le tonneau de bail de rambouillet donné
vie proulx sage de cocaîne longue lutte
contre alcool et drogue soirées de
débauche vers les clubs strip tease à
faire des partenariats avec les tags
chinois et c'est ça le sort de ces
dernières révélations il a accepté une
demande de plus que deux karts de la
business man
chinoise et les ir est notre services
fiscaux maintenant font-ils
investigations des impôts non payés donc
l'un des vers de terre et tout ça qu au
visage de présidente
parce que c'est son fils mais ce que la
question qu'on se pose parce que mon
compteur vdn voilà et et commis ces
fautes enquête nous il ya mais est ce
que cela peut impliquer son père est ce
que sont plutôt son père qui va devenir
président peut être impliqué dans ces
affaires ce qui serait plus gênant on
imagine c'est difficile de s'éloigner
pinceau qu elles sont bien aussi comme
sénateur de l'état du delaware qui était
un et est un peu petit clair aux etats
unis c'est un paradis fiscal
son cas aussi en déconnexion un arsène
dans les affaires et est le plus qu un
fouillis dans le rhône et les affaires
de famille bague le plus de mal qu'on
trouve et son cas n'a pas dissocier de
son fils parce qu'il y avait un autre
fils beau le fils aîné a traité le fils
cadettes et ball fils aîné était un
héros de la guerre et elle est juste ou
le contraire et à la perte de balle qui
est morte a profondément touché
président du pedn et il ne lâche pas son
fils
n'importe qui à la fin se mêla alterne
haydn à dubaï devra garder son fils sont
protection et donc il continuer à
s'associer avec son fils alors sur le
fond de la présidentielle le président
trump a multiplié les recours ont les
commandes tous les jours en justice pour
contester les élections concédant 50
défaite judiciaire pourtant il continue
de clamer que les élections étaient
truqué quel est l'objectif de donald
trump parce qu'il ne va pas finir par se
décrédibiliser si ce n'est pas déjà fait
aux yeux de beaucoup de monde au bond
les hypothèses le plus fortes et les
plus répandues sais que tu rentres
prêtait rona campagne permanente avec sa
base et sa base est devenu un peu comme
le culte 1,30 à l' accès sus direct sa
base à travers le sony via il n'a pas
besoin de grandes sociétés médiatiques
pour communiquer avec sa base et à il
peut répondre des idées parfois fausses
qui sera bien accepté dans ce culte et
il va continuer à cotiser un grande
lecture est républicain qui lui donne
influence dans le parti et peuvent
peut-être le protéger contre les charges
criminelles qui s'accumulent aussi
contre dans notre dernière question de
laisser y est le choix de nommer
l'ancien général lloyd austin et au
poste de ministre de la défense
il est critique et on l'a vu au sein
même du camp démocrate pour pourquoi
cette eau défiance le problème c'est que
comme on a un militaire de proportions
énormes aux états unis un départ en
défense qui pèse et qui de l'ontt les
prochaines neuf pays dans la mesure de
leur poids militaire du monde et à l'or
pourtant le risque c'est un coup
militaire c'est que les états unis
deviennent une régime militaire et donc
c'est symbolique peut être que ce soit
incident il est le général en question
était en retraite depuis quatre ans et
d'après la loi il faut sept ans mais
c'est ça
et a déjà prendre l'administration 30
king matrice à l'ancien général était à
démonter à suppose et le sénat a accepté
les questions si maintenant c est ce que
le sénat devra accepter encore
militaires dans le poste parce que les
bienvenus à paris centimes c'est
exceptionnel on ferait que protéines
smatis une seule fois une deuxième fois
ce domaine une tradition et après tout
si les général dirige le département de
défense le plus gros ce budget dans le
gouvernement américaine risque et enfin
militaire c'est une vraie crise merci
douglas wyeth professeur de droit
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et dans une trame
qui a annoncé la reconnaissance par les
états unis de la souveraineté marocaine
sur le sahara occidental
le roi mohamed 6 à lui une prise de
position historique américaine le
polisario condamne dans les termes les
plus forts la décision de donald trump à
une annonce qui arrive un mois après les
incidents de guerre guerre at situé dans
le sud-ouest du sahara occidental est et
négociations en cliquant le maroc le
front polisario l'algérie et la
mauritanie sont au point mort depuis
mars 2019 la reconnaissance par le
président américain de la souveraineté
marocaine sur le sahara occidental
risque donc d'accentuer ses tensions
dans la région de son côté l'onu affirme
ce soir que les discussions sur le
statut du territoire doivent se
poursuivre
et nouveau coup diplomatique de donald
trump cette fois-ci information
confirmée par rabat après les émirats
arabes unis le bahreïn et le soudan le
royaume chérifien devient le quatrième
pays arabes depuis août promettre
d'établir des relations diplomatiques
avec l'état hébreu
my ennemies netanyahu le premier
ministre israélien a salué cet accord
j'ai toujours cru que cette journée
historique deviendrait réalité un jour
j'ai toujours oeuvré pour cela je veux
remercier donald trump pour ses efforts
extraordinaires pour avoir mené la paix
en israël et les peuples du moyen-orient
+ président trump le peuple et l'état
d'israël seront éternellement
reconnaissant pour votre investissement
à notre égard et du nouveau dans les
investigations sur l' explosion
dévastatrice du port de la capitale
libanaise quatre mois après le drame le
juge chargé des enquêtes a inculpé
aujourd'hui le premier ministre
démissionnaire hassan diab et trois
anciens ministres
c'est la première fois qu'un chef du
gouvernement en exercice est inculpé
dans le cadre de ses fonctions et l'a
nommé judd le 4 août dernier de 1750
tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium explose
dans le port de beyrouth suite à un
incendie
bilan plus de 200 morts et 6000 500
blessés le port et des milliers de
logements de la capitale libanaise sont
détruits le produits explosifs étaient
entreposés dans un hangar du port depuis
sept ans aucune précaution n'avait été
prise par les autorités malgré les
alertes lancées à plusieurs reprises
depuis ce drame une enquête judiciaire
est en cours pour comprendre les dessous
de cette catastrophe
fadi sawan le juge libanais chargé de
l'anc est inculpé ce jeudi pour
négligence et cause de décès les tout
premiers dirigeants politiques parmi eux
l'ex chef du gouvernement libanais
hassan diab
hassan diab a la conscience tranquille
il est sûr d'avoir les mains propres et
d'avoir géré le dossier de manière
responsable et transparente
ce ciblage surprenant va au delà de la
personne et attaque le poste de premier
ministre en tant que tel
hassan diab a fourni toutes les
informations dont ils disposaient
concernant ce dossier le juge sawan
viole la constitution et contourne le
parlement hassan diab a démissionné
quelques jours après l'explosion du port
de beyrouth poussé par la colère de la
rue
une démission certes mais l'ex premier
ministre continue de gérer les affaires
courantes du liban en attendant la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
trois autres dirigeants sont également
inculpés ali hassan khalil ancien
ministre des finances puis youssef
fenianos et ghazi zeaiter qui ont été à
la tête du ministère des travaux publics
et du transport
selon une source judiciaire le juge a
décidé de les inculper pour ne pas avoir
pris les mesures nécessaires pour éviter
l'explosion dévastatrice et les énormes
dégâts
le juge fadi sawan pourrait commencer
d'ailleurs à interroger hassan diab
lundi prochain et les trois ex ministres
les jours suivants au total 25 personnes
notamment des responsables du port et
des douanes ont été arrêtés dans le
cadre de l' enquête selon les autorités
libanaises
sauf que le pouvoir en place n'a
toujours pas publié de conclusion quatre
mois après l'explosion du port de
beyrouth
la classe dirigeante qui refusent
toujours l'idée d'une enquête
internationale sur cette affaire
pourtant les appels à des investigations
indépendantes au liban tout comme à
l'étranger se sont multipliés et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct depuis
beyrouth au liban avec antoine sfeir
avant cassé notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir antoine sfeir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france ce sont les
premiers responsables politiques être
accusé dans cette affaire c'est un
tournant bonsoir effectivement c'est un
tournant oui vous savez le liban est
dans une tourmente économique politique
sur le plan des affaires sociales et
puis a eu ce cri contre l'humanité le 4
ou délits qui a vraiment secoué le pays
et le corps économique du pays
effectivement le juge d'instruction
auprès de la cour de justice a pris une
position aujourd'hui c'est un tournant
juridique et politique en même temps
juridique parce que irrite pas mal de
humeurs d'un fort au de fausses infos
que le juge n'a pas pris position
jusqu'ici 1 et des mois écoulés il ya
des gens blessés il ya d'autres fuyaient
vous savez actuellement il a pris cette
position
ça a commencé à donner un sérieux plus
solide et plus consolidée a à l'esprit
qu'à la destruction à lanquais à tout ce
qui est jusqu'à la pause avec les
mécanismes juridiques et judiciaires
sur le plan politique je vous dis
franchement c'est pas facile qu'un
premier ministre sortant mais qui est
toujours en fonction voulu qui apparaît
encore un gouvernement un nouveau
gouvernement
suite aux poules et les troubles
politiques qui secouent le pays
actuellement c'est une décision c'est
une première qu'un juge d'instruction
plus de la cour de justice a pris
position contre le premier ministre
et toi listes et des travaux publics
c'est un tournant il ya une polémique
sur le plan juridique ici si les
présidents et les ministres selon
transféré devant la cour spéciale pour
le jugement des ministres et des
présidents au palais du parlement qui
n'a jamais fonctionné d'ailleurs elle
qui a acquis qui s'avère était caduc ce
le plan fonctionnel ou bien ils sont ils
se sont installés devant lui le juge lui
même et c'est la justice et le pouvoir
judiciaire qui va voir tout ça observé
plein de positions suite aux enquêtes
qui vont avoir eu un premier ministre
responsable mais pas coupable
est ce que c'est ce qui risque de se
passer lors de ce procès pour reprendre
une phrase célèbre d'un ancien ministre
français
il ya vraiment une part évidente de
responsabilité dans cette affaire de la
part de l'ex premier ministre libanais
selon vous donc avocat je veux pas dire
si les goupilles nous
dans qu'avocat je veux observer de loin
car j'ai pas les informations précises
et les détails de l'enquète mais je veux
vous dire que même si le premier sortant
fut accusée par le club ni par le juge
d'instruction aujourd'hui ça veut pas
dire qu'il est coupable peut-être ya des
des soucis des éclaircissements des et
les relations à faire peut-être il a été
accusé vous il y à rio la désinfo qui
vont être laissés leur enquête là c'est
un c'est un long processus
c'est pas facile de prouver que le
premier ministre sortant ehoud par duke
il n'a qu'elle n'a vécu au pouvoir s'il
voulait en guinée au palais du
gouvernement que quelques mois alors ça
c'est une première question la seconde
question il ya eu depuis quelques jours
il une accusation contre des ancêtres
ajoute t elle au coude et de l'enrichir
encore c'est à dire souvent des des en
cas de corruption c'est le même principe
aussi c'est qu'il ya des points
d'interrogation ce plan si quelqu'un est
accusé il ya des fondements juridiques
et des faits bien précis et concis alors
ils doivent être arrêtés
sinon ce sont des accusations en prime
et on vante des accusations je peux pas
dire plus maintenant on doit s'attendre
à des enquêtes plus élargie à des
polémiques politiques de tous bords pour
relancer ou données
un peu plus ses vieux os à lenquête
c'est un clip contre l'humanité et c'est
pas moi qui vis à ces sont les réalités
c'est il ya des centaines qui ont vu
qu'ils ont été tuées et il ya tout un
pays qui a été mobilisée alors il faut
qu'il y ait une enquête sérieuse
sinon il ya beaucoup d'organisations
beaucoup des familles victimes qui vont
aller qui vous demander de plus en plus
des enquêtes indépendantes ou
internationaux dernière question
rapidement peut-on faire confiance en la
justice on a eu des invités c'est qu'ils
nous disaient oh là on doute quand même
de l'indépendance de la justice et
et et qu'il y ait vraiment un résultat
fiable ce que vous le pensez au chai
effectivement dans que juriste tant que
politologue que je peux vous dire que
j'ai confiance en quelques juges on n'a
pas confiance dans un système pourri le
système ici c'est que la politique est
bien omniprésente au niveau de justice
au liban
c'est pour cela dans les brosses et de
corruption qu'on n'a pas vu aucun aucune
personne aucun personnage politique du
monde de la justice de l'arrestation qui
a été emprisonné et ça c'est une grande
question aussi mais avec la lutte du des
jeunes du liban avec la le support de la
communauté nationale
on va voir un jour c'est un bis ce jour
ça va nous coûter beaucoup plus merci
beaucoup antoine sfeir avocat merci à
vous d'avoir été avec nous et c'est la
fin de cette édition rendez vous de
cette émission plutôt dans quelques
minutes pour 1 point complet sur
l'actualité avec david khalifa
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer
si aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture
et puis les espaces naturels c'est grâce
à la chasse grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse est la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
en grande partie conservée grâce à la
gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui vous
avez vingt trois ans vous êtes une femme
qu'est ce que vous espérez apporter
justement à ce monde de la chasse si je
peux aider avec avec ce que je fais sur
les réseaux sociaux etc skhira a montré
un autre aspect de la chasse et à donner
envie à certaines personnes de la
découvrir
[Musique]
on
sow
[Musique]